All we need to do to solve these two problems is plug the right numbers into
our equations up here. Let's start out with the quarterly compounding option.
What do we know? Well, P equals 20,000, r equals 0.04, n equals 4 and t equals
5. Great. Now, let's just plug these numbers in to solve for A, since that's
what we're looking for. A will equal 20,000 times 1 plus 0.04 over 4, all of
that raised to the 4 times 5 power. This simplifies to 20,000 times 1.01 to the
20. If we plug this into a calculator and round, we end up with $24,403.80.
Now, on to monthly compounding. We do almost exactly the same thing. In fact,
all of our information is the same, except that n is not 4. This time n is 12,
since there are 12 months in 1 year. For A then, we have 20,000 times 1 plus
0.04 over 12 raised to the 5 times 20 or 60 power. Plugging this into a
calculator gives us $24,419.93. Although, these two total balances aren't too
far off from one another, Grant will end up with slightly more money if he goes
with the monthly compounding interest choice. And look at that, after 5 years
in either case, he'll earn over $4,400 just by keeping his money in his
account. That's a pretty good deal.